okay [ __ ] putting sack party look
good don't show your gun down I won't
run yeah I'm good I felt that the moment
we met that connection what forbidden
love oh my god can I just shoot this guy
Sean D play nice now hmm you got the
stuff Pierce good a lil me Fred you did
that on purpose all right let's go stag
hunting Oh better think you can pick a
fight with stag by yourself you have a
booty call to get to go to pick up a
that Stan I you know how to use a multi
yeah that's a shame oh Jesus I was just
asking well I'm get some recruits that
was Al Green Earth so room for one more
what the [ __ ] come on me one more come
on cut I'm that's if oh yeah gotta lever
is wrong with you God and let's get some
minor batches
let's go backs let's grab a chance
you
what the [ __ ] i break but i was in the
[ __ ] air
okay I'm can't we're good yeah I [ __ ]
them up if anything like this is like
the loudest you can [ __ ] being like a
[ __ ] military I'm be like this little
[ __ ] in front of me he got [ __ ] all
right he got his dick sucked by little
my no mama is he not heavy stock in this
area [ __ ] a chef
funny p push a car into the cop car it's
like not your fault it's a [ __ ] dogs
and tapestries a perfect match ok
burn [ __ ] I missed that one okkk our
guests are coming the party favors all
set yes be careful not to set off the
bombs when you get course I'll be
monitoring stags approach from our
security room yes sure the current car
we got these [ __ ] rihanna's
it's an return
hmm
okay look at all these these just like
an Apes walking the streets job less
it's like D say
well I feel again shout out here man
[ __ ] it like Detroit yeah through worse
the truth like New Jersey
oh shut
my [ __ ] bikini uh yeah I have flowed
error on it about half a chance like I
ugga I'm here I'm here the end of North
all right use a rocket launcher I left
to set off the bombs when stan getz
course [ __ ]
ok [ __ ] mess that
ok
good God God
shut
go help Iola I want this side filtration
stepped where's my eyelash oh [ __ ] make
them all pay and Melvin was [ __ ] dead
looks like they're focusing on the south
side [ __ ] guy
ok
chef [ __ ] say
ok where the [ __ ] snipers where the
other snipers
chef
they sent it into the north side i SAT
like a higher up didn't I wish eyes on
the top top floor [ __ ] man any more emo
[ __ ] no more huh I have the [ __ ] i
can't rewrite their pocket
holy [ __ ] that was close
[ __ ] I get this guy
oh my god how do you destroy the tanks
ok
holy [ __ ] my white [ __ ]
come on
ok
remember this one wow this pistols are
like the fast it
boss I'm on my way back he'll love our
new toy get down there before someone
killed him yeah oh [ __ ] okay thank me
I'm gone I'm gone I'm gone hi [ __ ]
yeah can I call for more bodies shut can
I call for all like our Johnny tag
[ __ ] jaw is dying anywhere sweetie
just tell me the surprise was worth it
Hey oh yeah let's head up and I'll show
you
can I like hijack this
someone had better buy me a drink
wow I am decimating
05
[ __ ] this is so much better
ok
I was really shocked that out it's a
laser targeting system who wants to call
down an air strike oh [ __ ] right okay
and ideas ok shag away from the wait I
think right come on stop moving I love
him there we go
the same
well I'd like infinite
yeah so I can get on look crazy right
guys I like to keep things j rated tryna
to shut his tanks but it's like you know
how it is China get the gum I found on
anything like it sounds slow okay
one up a stag right there right there
come on right right
no way ha
what are the [ __ ] aircraft here we go
I got a sock and finished
shut
hey tillery China Calla stack oh oh shet
not chef
get to the roof and let's get out of
here okay let's get out of here [ __ ]
Sean day oh yeah
surrender kid we got the perimeter yeah
we got your poster boy I'm once tagged
out of my city not gonna happen Chad's
mission is to eradicate the gangs of
steelport well where to focus the
firepower at my call released Burke and
we'll hammer the syndicate for a while
give you boys a little breathing room
how you want to play it give Josh to
Shonda hide from my one true love in her
cause I love Sean D and I to be together
and I swear her enemies will be my
enemies Oh
manfredi know about it open fire on the
building
I got
awesome awesome can I see
congratulations are in order commander
not quite the saints are still at large
i'm so over i need leverage on the stage
bringing the target for questioning
they're going to run to brown digging
them out won't be easy if we were easy I
wouldn't waste your time understood sir
I'll find her I got good you know yeah
we may I lost the battle but we're more
in the war you know Sam today thanks i'm
watching let's just thank ya
dips out for Harambee